Guys, did you know what the religious
authorities called Peter and John? Or at
least when Luke records their reaction
and what they thought about them, you
know what they were called?
>> No,
>> they were called idiots.
>> The word is idiote.
The word where you get idiot. says,
"When they saw Peter and John, that they
were
unskilled, untrained men," meaning they
were not taught
by rabbis. They didn't have any formal
theological education, and they're
pretty much unlearned,
unskilled,
not taught formally. Didn't have a
formal theological education, but they
were also idiots. The word is idiote.
It's the word where we get idiot. not
lying. So what does that tell you? What
did Jesus choose? People whom the
scholars thought were idiots.
So there's hope for you, right?
>> Yes.
>> So Amen. There's hope for you, too,
right?
>> Amen.
>> Amen. That's I wanted to see if you're
going to react. See, you're humble. You
didn't say, "What do you mean I'm an
idiot?" Oh, so you think you're wise?
Okay. Watch here.
Acts 4:13.
Having understood that men unschooled uh
grammati see they were not
taught theology they didn't have any
formal theological education and what
are they idiote they were unschooled
idiots idiote
>> yeah I see it
>> right here idiote
but you know what
it says idiot that's where you get the
word idiot from I'm not lying
So when I call you an idiot, rejoice,
brother, because Peter and John were
idiots by the world's standards.
>> If they were idiots, what are we?
>> Yeah. So why would you then be shocked
everyone that God appears to simple
people, uneducated people, people who
are not brilliant, who are not
considered geniuses
or movers and shakers of the world.
Because Jesus loves all creatures. And
Jesus has compassion for those who are
oppressed, looked down upon, belittled,
whom others reject, and show no respect
or discard because they don't think
they're good enough.
God's heart is for those people,
>> right?
>> Yes.
>> So it says idiot idiot. Again, it comes
from the word idiot, ignorant, rude,
unlearned. Right. Idiot. Idiot. All
right. Unlettered.
So there you go. So why would it shock
us? Idiot. Now, but one thing what's
beautiful though is that they noted that
they were with Jesus. See that's the
key. I'm going to show you the verse how
powerful the verse is. You want to see
the word from idiosation
is compare idiot.
>> See that?
>> Yes. Sam, you're lying, man. Yeah. No,
it says it right there. But what was the
key factor? They noticed that they had
been with Jesus. That's the key. Now,
let me break down the meat of this. You
ready for me to break down the meat of
this?
>> Now, this is after they had done a
miracle. There was a paralytic who used
to beg. When Peter and John went and it
said, "In the name of Jesus Christ of
Nazareth, get up and walk." And they
lift him up. And he leapt and his legs
were fully restored. The religious
authorities knew this man was a
paralytic,
but now they're seeing him fully
restored and his feet was much stronger
and healthier than their own. They
couldn't refute them that this miracle
had been done in the name of Jesus
because the miracle's right there
because they asked them in the chapter
by what power or name did you do this?
in the name of Jesus whom you rejected
whom God has raised. This man has been
made whole and there is no other person
no other name under heaven by which men
are to be saved.
So they proclaim Jesus and that's Jesus
who healed them because we asked Jesus
to heal him which means Jesus is not
dead he's alive because if he's dead how
did he heal this man and what did they
say and seeing the man who had been
healed standing with them they had
nothing to say in reply the miracle shut
their mouths but they still did not
repent but here's the key which gives
hope to everyone now as they observe the
confidence Peter and John because the
spirit had emboldened and filled them to
glorify Christ without fear of any
repercussions that they were uneducated,
unordinary men. So they were unschooled,
no formal theological training,
ordinary, meaning that from their
standard idiots because they're just
fishermen. They were marveling. They
were shocked like how the hell
does this man speak with such confidence
and knowledge and boldness?
Where did he get this from? But now
watch the key. And began to recognize
them as having been with Jesus. That's
the key. See, right that one line right
there, that one line for everyone
listening, that's the key. The key there
that Luke wants you to see by
inspiration of the spirit is
it doesn't matter how many PhDs you
have, which is true. It doesn't matter
how many professors you've had. What
really matters is this. What really
matters is
are you spending time with Jesus?
Do you know Jesus? Do you walk with
Jesus? Are you with Jesus? Have you
spent time with him? Because Jesus is
the one who makes you wise.
See, that's the key.
I have met PhDs, I'm letting you know,
scholars
that could not defend the truth of
Christianity against
some of these Muslims. You don't believe
me, go see Shabi debating some top
Christian scholars eating them up. I've
had professors, again, you're going to
think I'm boasting. Believe me, I know I
am scum and filth to get puffed up and
think I am holy. I am not. I want to be
and I ask God for mercy. When I was at
the Evangelical, Theological,
Philosophical Society, not only did you
have one for Israel coming up to me,
brethren, I am not lying. Professors
teaching in seminaries said, "Hey,
you're Sam Shimon." I go, "Yeah." He
goes, "I want to thank God for your
ministry. I watch you and I'm learning."
And I'm blown away. I swear I want to I
was going to ask him, you're learning
from me and you're teaching. Then what
are you teaching if you're going to
learn from me? You understand the point?
>> Yes.
>> And I want again, believe me when I tell
you the Lord knows that I know I am
filth. I'm garbage. I'm a sinner. And I
beg God not turn me over.
But God has been pleased to bless me
with this wisdom. And I pray I use it to
magnify him till I die until he returns.
But when a professor is telling me he's
watching me, learning from me, all the
more reason why you shouldn't be going
to seminary.
>> Yeah. Wasn't that also the se the
meeting where one of the stop scholars
gave a very bad explanation of the
trinity?
>> One of them
can't explain the trinity. Okay. But
now, how does this tie in with Jesus's
promise? Remember it says they had no
formal theological training.
>> Yes. Because that's what uneducated
means. They were not trained formally by
the rabbis. Idiots. By way of testimony,
again, by way of testimony, I was thrown
out of high school. Thrown out of high
school. GED.
I had to go get a GED. Never been to
college, never been to university, no
seminary, no priest or pastor discipling
me. And here I stand.
>> I'm a proof as unworthy as I am. And I'm
not the only one who's proof. Anyone who
spent time with Christ and sought the
spirit will be given that wisdom. We are
the proof of how true the Bible is that
if you trust in Christ, seek Christ, cry
out to him, he will give you the wisdom
to confound the wise men of this age.
>> Amen.
>> So it shouldn't shock you that the
Lord's going to appear to simpleans like
me, like you.
Yes,
>> because Peter was a nobody when Jesus
called him, but now he's a somebody
because Jesus called him. In other
words, Jesus calls you when you're
nobody and he makes you great not for
your glory, but to glorify his name
through you. And the love of Christ is
as he glorifies himself through you,
whether you like it or not, he's
exalting you. See, this is how Jesus
works. And it makes me want to cry.
Why does it make me want to cry? Because
when Jesus uses you and you let him use
you more and more less of you, the more
he shines through you and as a result,
the more he elevates you in the eyes of
people and the more people love you
because of the Jesus shining through
you. And so the Lord's way of blessing
you by allowing him to work through you
is the more Jesus shines through you,
the more you point people to Jesus, the
more people fall in love with Jesus, the
more they're going to love you and the
more
they will be praying for you. See,
that's how the Lord does it.
>> Yes.
>> Why do you think people love me? Do you
think they love me? Because me?
>> No. Because the only thing that makes me
lovable is when I let Jesus shine
through me. That's it.
When you get to know me as a person, I'm
repulsive and reprehensible. And I mean
this, anything good,
anything praiseworthy and beautiful is
because of Jesus shining through me. Put
Jesus away from me. I'm reprehensible.
I'm repulsive. I am. And I know it. And
believe me when I'm telling you, I'm not
trying to be humble. I'm being honest
with every one of you. That's why I say
don't idolize me. The only good thing in
me is Jesus. And the more Jesus shines
through me, the less of me, the more
loving and caring, compassionate and
humble I become.
>> It's all because of Jesus. It's only
because of Jesus that anyone could love
someone like me. And when they look at
me and all, why do you think people are
not on me? Me? Because of the Jesus that
shines through me.
Anyway, yeah. You any other questions?
No, that was it. Thank you.
>> I don't care what St. Fina says about
you. You're a good kid.
>> Yeah. I'm praying for you and your
daughters. Amen. I love you, brother.
Remember, if I had a son, it would be
you. And I'd name him David because
that's your name.